[Music]
what's up Wolfgang Avengers infinity war
is officially two weeks away and with
each day closer that we get I feel like
we get a new trailer or we get some sort
of leaked information about Avengers
infinity war and some information that
we've gotten sporadically over time is
about Peter Dinklage's role in Avengers
infinity war it wasn't too long ago
where it was confirmed that he would in
fact be in the movie when they released
a poster for Avengers infinity war and
his name was credited on the bottom
there have been many different theories
and speculations on what character he'll
play in Avengers infinity war and today
in this video I will tell you mine but
before we get started let me tell you
why you should subscribe to my channel
I'll listen to you till this is empty as
god is in danger and people are dying we
need to get back that need your help
finished by just push the red button so
for a really long time it was thought
that Peter Dinklage would not actually
be playing an actual character but that
he would be doing the voice-over for
someone in the Black Order or as they're
calling it in the MCU the children of
Thanos but I think this is pretty much
debunked because we have seen pictures
of him on set with red hair after the
pictures came out fans of course started
coming up with their own theories and it
is widely believed that he will be
playing the character pip the troll I
however do not believe this the two main
reasons that I don't believe that he
will be playing pip the troll is one he
is mostly associated with Adam warlock
and it has been stated that Adam warlock
will not make his debut until 2020 and
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 I know
sadface I will hurt you for this
the day will come when you think you're
safe and happy and your joy will turn to
ashes in your mouth
and reason number two co-director Joe
Russo said it may take you a beat or two
but you'll certainly recognize him as
you can see here there isn't anything -
in particular about pip the troll I
don't think I'd have a problem
recognizing Peter Dinklage if he played
him but you know how it might be kind of
hard to recognize him if he had a big
old red beard to accompany that red hair
yes I think he is going to be playing
King III who is the king of the dwarves
of Nadav Alire to me this just makes the
most sense I've said it in a few of my
past videos but the doors of Nadal er
who forged Thor's original hammer
mjolnir not only did they Forge Muller
they also forged Odin's spear gun near
we know that Thor gets a new hammer
Stormbreaker or what they're calling
Stormbreaker so he's obviously going to
need to forge this new hammer many
believe that this scene right here is
Thor forging the new hammer we even have
this scene where he's asking somebody in
the same place are you ready I
personally believe that he is on the
doubler and I personally believe that he
is talking to a tree co-directors
Anthony and Joe Russo have also stated
that his character will be a major role
in Avengers infinity war that will carry
on to Avengers 4 so here's my personal
theory Thanos is going to kick
everyone's butt in Avengers infinity war
I think some Avengers will die but who I
think will actually stay alive is Iron
Man obviously since Thanos is going to
defeat them they're going to need to
come up with a new game plan to defeat
Thanos and what I think that will be is
better armor for Iron Man I then think
they'll take the route of the fear
itself and earth-616 comic story lines
and these storylines iron man takes his
bleeding-edge armor which is the armor
that he will have an Infinity Ward and
ghosts in a dollar and plunges himself
with the armor on into a vat of molten
guru which is the metal that Thor's
original hammer Mjolnir is made out of
he think comes out his new armor being
cloaked by room metal and we get the
iron
destroyer I'm not sure if they'll really
bring the iron destroyer into the MCU
but I do think that Peter Dinklage will
play Eitri it's a significant character
that will help Thor
gorgeous new hammer and can be carried
on to Avengers 4 this is my own theory
so of course I'm a little biased but I
would love to see this play out on
screen what do you guys think of this
theory and what role do you think Peter
Dinklage will play in Avengers infinity
war let me know in the comments below
and please don't say medic it's not
gonna happen be sure to give this video
a thumbs up and the reason you should
subscribe to my channel is because
that's what heroes do thank you so much
for watching
woof woof
[Music]